top academics are demanding the firing
of a french minister who's claimed
universities quote islamoleftism is
eating away at society
stay with me here their open letter
warned that higher education minister
frederick vidal's real aim was to stop
the teaching of many
progressive ideas altogether we can only
deplore the indigence
of frederick vidal who's using the
repertoire of the far right about
imaginary islamoleftism just like in
urban hungary
bolsonaro's brazil or dudas poland
post-colonial
and decolonial studies the work on
racial discrimination
gender status and intersectionality are
specifically targeted
islamic leftism then is an increasingly
popular term used by those who see an
alliance between progressives and
muslims
to weaken society in october another
french minister claimed
islamic leftism was quote wreaking havoc
on the country's higher education
facilities
vidal insisted the threat was real
i think that islam and leftism is eaten
away at our society as a whole
and universities are not immune and are
part of our society
her inflammatory comments are part of
what many in france see as a growing
assault on muslims in the country
following a raft of
islamist inspired terror attacks many
found the minister's remarks
unacceptable though
[Music]
i think the government is openly
islamophobic the media
all say the same the bitterness towards
muslims
i think it's nonsense i believe that
such aggression against muslims is an
overreaction and it is completely
incomprehensible
i have a feeling that muslims have no
right to live freely in france
there is a confusion between the terms
extremists and the person who practices
his religion peacefully
so some french have this image of
muslims as
terrorists or extremists and it is not
right
once again we're talking about using a
strategy that we have known for a long
time
distraction and polemics it's exhausting
it takes away my powers
it makes me sick
i don't like this concept i think it's
the wrong wording by the right wing
movement
but i don't really like that confusion
a french sociologist told us the
minister's words are
just the government's latest onslaught
on academia
the most shocking thing is the
opportunism and cynicism
i don't know what to call what the
minister has done at a time
when the academic world is isolated
disorganized and
in deep disaster in the middle of a
pandemic saying this to students who are
here to learn
we're at the university to study to do
research work
i'm here before you tonight not because
i like it but because we all suffer in
the climate
imposed by the government for months now
you